there's been a lot of talk about when
the British government will force
companies like whatsapp to introduce a
backdoor into their encryption so the
police and government can read your
messages if they need to as a record
this they haven't done it yet but the
laws that could let them do so in the
future are already in place and here's
something you might not expect me to say
that sounds like a reasonable idea after
all backdoors have been allowed for
old-school phone conversations for
decades they're called wiretaps and if a
criminal investigation has enough
evidence that they can get a legal
warrant then they can look inside your
postal mail they can listen to your
phone calls and they can intercept your
text messages and it's called a wiretap
because many years ago the police would
literally be attaching a device to a
physical phone wire so for anyone who
grew up knowing that anyone who grew up
with computers like this like pretty
much every politician in government well
it seems reasonable that should also
extend to for example what's up so why
not well first let's look at the
technical detail it all depends on who
is holding the keys modern encryption
uses complicated math that is easy for a
computer to calculate one way but almost
impossible to work out in Reverse a
really simple example if I ask you to
multiply two prime numbers together like
13 times 17 you can do that by just
hitting a few keys on calculator and
because those were prime numbers we know
that's the only way to make 221 by
multiplying two whole numbers together
other than 221 times one and that's not
really helpful but if I ask you what two
prime numbers were multiplying together
to make 161 there is no way to work that
out quickly there are a few shortcuts
that you can take but it's still
basically a brute-force method now
imagine you're not trying to work out
161 but instead something like this and
you start to see the scale of the
problem and that's just a simple example
modern cryptography uses way more
complicated one-way operations the
important part is that you can have a
computer do map that simple one way but
could take longer than the lifetime of
the universe to brute-force back the
result is that you can have two keys to
massive numbers one public one private
you send your public key out to the
world anyone can put
a message with it the message gets
conversed to what looks like random
noise even that same public key can't
convert it back but you can take that
noise and use your private key and only
your private key to decrypt it when you
want to send the message back you use
their public key and they use their
private key to decrypt it and the
beautiful part of this it there's no
need to exchange keys in advance what
you don't have to work out old-school
one-time pads or anything like that you
can post your public key out on the
internet for all to see and as long as
you keep that private key secret no one
else can read your messages this is a
system that has been tested under
incredibly harsh conditions for decades
it works the catch is it's really
unfriendly to use it's difficult enough
to get them to join the new messaging
service as it is let alone bring their
friends a lock now you have to generate
these weird key things as well if you
lose your phone or somehow forget that
key or your hard drive crashes me I'm
going to backup all your messages are
gone lost as random noise forever email
that works this way has been around for
decades but it's too complicated and
it's too unfriendly for those people the
security wasn't worth the effort so
instead webmail services along with
Facebook Twitter and everyone else
didn't worry about that early on they're
mostly unencrypted but rapidly realize
that was a bad idea so now they use
regular web encryption that padlock in
your browser to make sure that no one on
your network can see password or your
messages while they're in transit and
that's the threat that most people have
to be worried about but they do have the
content of those messages in plain text
or something plugs to it and those
companies can give that back to you
whenever you want which means that when
a government comes along with a legal
warrant the companies can also give you
messages to them but this was fine right
this was reasonable this was an
acceptable compromise between security
and usability or at least it was until
it was revealed that in short every
major government was keeping a copy of
pretty much everything everyone ever
wrote at which point a few companies
decided that actually they really didn't
want to take the risk of anyone not even
their own employees being able to even
theoretically access the messages that
people were sending the result is
whatsapp and I message and the many
smaller apps like them they have end
and encryption your phone generates a
public and private key for you
automatically and it changes public keys
behind the scenes while you're writing
your first message to someone everything
after that is encrypted and it's all
automatic and so what's happened is you
aren't open source or in theory they
could steal your private key as well or
quietly issue a fake one to someone and
sit in the middle listening but in
practice people would notice sure there
are small loopholes that could work in
particular circumstances but the odds
are remote and security researchers are
already decompiling and tearing apart
every version of every messenger program
just to see if someone's put a backdoor
into it the short version is if any of
these apps get served with a government
warrant right now the most they could do
is say how much - people have been
talking and maybe roughly where they
were but never what they were talking
about more than that is literally
mathematically impossible but it's
impossible only because of the way they
design their systems and that is the
vulnerability a government could makes a
legal requirement for Apple and Facebook
to quietly add a backdoor in all their
encryption if they want to sell anything
in their country I've heard this phrased
as outlawing maths but that's a bit like
saying that making punching a stranger
in the face illegal is outlawing hands
and if Apple and Facebook refused to add
a backdoor a government could well
theoretically they could ban their
phones or banned their apps from sale or
prosecute the people in charge or block
Facebook who owned what that or they
could tell enterprise to block their
services or they could look in practice
they're going to find the company Apple
and Facebook have local addresses they
pay some tax sitting on the sidelines I
would love to see the British government
off against couple and see who blinked
first but companies have vowed to
foreign governments loads of times in
the past Blackberry like the Indian
government have full access to users
chats and web history back in 2013 the
only reason whatsapp can't read your
messages is because they had
deliberately chosen to design their
systems that way they were just as
popular without encryption it was after
a thought they've been going for years
before they switched encryption Ark this
with a human decision not an inevitable
fact of technology so why is an
encryption backdoor such a bad idea
well if there's a back door it can and
will be abused local British authorities
already used our surveillance laws the
ones that were brought in to stop
terrorism to monitor loud dogs barking
crackdown on illegal feeding of pigeons
and to spy on some parents to see if
they actually live near enough to a
particular school they want to get their
kids into now is this useful preventing
crime sure under the argument that if
you have nothing to hide you have
nothing to fear maybe they shouldn't
have illegally Bend those pigeons and
yes you watching this you probably have
nothing to hide nothing to fear from the
current government in your country but
laws and governments change and beside
that the Internet in the apps we use on
our phones are global if you allow that
door here you're also allowing it for
another country's government to spy on
its opponents and another to spy on
people that they suspect might be gay or
who use marijuana or who are Christian
or whichever thing is illegal in that
country in 50 years maybe you'll be part
of a country where eating meat has been
outlawed and the government will want to
come after you for tracking down the
illegal bacon trading ring that your
friends a part of nothing to hide only
works if the folks in power share the
values of you and everyone you know
entirely and always will to make it
worse on the surface this seems like
it's equivalent to a regular old-school
wiretap but it's not depending on how
the backdoors set up a government might
not just be able to get what someone is
sending now they could get the whole
message history perhaps years of
messages back and forth with hundreds or
thousands of other people it's not just
a look into what a person is saying it's
an overreaching look into the thoughts
of many many people it's that
long-forgotten naked picture that
someone sent five years ago it's that
angry essay they wrote in school in
which they completely disagree with now
it's not just what are they saying it's
what have they ever said that's all
assuming the backdoor doesn't get abused
by folks with more personal grievances
all it takes is one rogue employee in
the government or as a messaging app and
we've got a huge amount of personal
information being leaked either of the
public at large or of specific people
that someone would like to take revenge
on it fails the bitter X test can
someone with an agenda you
is this to ruin a life an AP
investigation found hundreds of cases
where police officers and civilian staff
in the u.s. looked at private
information for personal reasons and
let's not start on what would happen if
a hacker or some other government's
intelligence service got access to the
back door or how does it make it much
more risky to report abuses of
government power on any scale there is
an argument that it would all be worth
it that all those drawbacks would be a
small price to pay for stopping very
rare bad things I disagree but that's an
opinion not a fact but an encryption
backdoor wouldn't stop bad things
happening the problem with stopping
terrorism right now is not a lack of
information
the Manchester bomber was reported to
the authorities five times including by
his own friends and family one anonymous
source inside the UK security services
told Reuters there's any time there are
500 people in being investigated and
around 3,000 people of interest for
scale just to reassure you that talking
about point zero zero five percent of
the UK population but the way to solve
this is not more data it's having enough
police officers and security staff with
enough time to do their jobs and
investigate and let's be clear anyone
who wanted secure communication for evil
purposes would just use something else
any of thousands of smaller services
that the government hasn't noticed yet
or that they couldn't possibly have
jurisdiction over or if even that is not
an option they can come up with a code
themselves even just in jokes and
references that no one else understands
so when I say that an encryption
backdoor sounds like a reasonable idea I
mean it it sounds reasonable like a lot
of ideas sound reasonable when you
express them in one or two sentences but
the devil is in the detail if we could
replicate the way wiretap used to work
limited in scope and time requiring a
warrant and some physical effort not
including the history of everything that
someone's ever said and not open to
repressive governments elsewhere in the
world then sure I would absolutely be in
favor of it building an encryption
backdoor isn't impossible but building a
reasonable one is thank you to everyone
who helped proofread my script and to
everyone here I mean Cambridge Centre
for computing history who've let me film
with this wonderful old equipment
you